bonsoir valéry giscard d'estaing
demain soir à la télévision raymond
barre aujourd'hui à lyon pour un appel à
l'effort national
jacques chirac à la veille de son
entrevue à l'elysée
favorable à un pacte majoritaire comme
on le voit la semaine politique qui
commence demain va permettre de
clarifier pas mal d'inconnues nous
allons y revenir je vous rappelle
également au préalable tiercé dans le
prix du président de la république le 1
le 5 et le 21 qui ne devrait pas faire
d'ailleurs de gros rapports car
apparemment les favoris se sont bien
comportés et puis je voudrais tout de
suite revenir à cette tentative
d'attentât commises la nuit dernière aux
usines renault de flins antenne 2 a été
le premier pratiquement sur les lieux
avant les pompiers qui aurait pu faire
de gros dégâts
elle n'avait été découverte très vite
par la police si tout avait bien
fonctionné la nuit dernière 120 mèche
comme celle ci se seraient allumés en
même temps dans 120 réservoir de r12
provoquant ainsi autant d'explosion
elles étaient judicieusement placé
aurait pu détruire ou endommager environ
1500 véhicules renault
sur les 4000 présent dans cette carrière
qui sert de parking lorsque les
entrepôts habituel de renault à flins
sont complets ici pas de murs ni même de
grillage aucun éclairage seulement trois
gardiens un an post les deux autres font
la ronde cette nuit ils n'ont rien
remarqué
c'est ce matin vers 9h15 rondier tribut
sur les fils qui relie plusieurs
voitures l' alerte est donnée aussitôt
on découvre alors sous le capot des 120
voitures piégées un système de fils
électriques allant de la batterie au
réservoir d'essence
un minuteur est relié à des groupes de
dix ou douze véhicules
ce sont ses fils que le rondier a
remarqué le matin les portes de ces
voitures ne sont pas fermées la clé de
contact et sur le tableau de bord il y a
deux à trois litres d'essence dans le
réservoir
le travail des saboteurs et faciliter la
mèche
et écrivaine une solution pour faire mes
choix pour avoir un allumage à
retardement et au bout de
minute ou une minute et demie selon
comment c'est réglé la presse a mis le
feu à toutes les petites paillettes ce
qui fait le coup de feu dans le
réservoir
c'est un beau travail ça c'est du bon
travail pour combien de temps à peu près
pour installer sa votre avis mais ça
dépend ça dépend quand il faut qu'elle
ce qu'ils ont quelques heures quand même
quelques pourquoi ça a échoué à votre
avis comme il faut hypothèse peu
probable car les gardiens n'ont rien
remarqué cette nuit autre hypothèse des
réservoirs ne contenait pas assez
d'essence mais plus que les causes
techniques qui ont provoqué l'échec de
cet attentat c'est l'identité de ses
auteurs qui recherchait aujourd'hui
d'affaires d'ailleurs qu'il faut
peut-être lié à l'assassinât de tram ni
le meurtrier de pierrot verne le 78e
prix du président de la république cet
après midi à auteuil a manqué à sa
tradition la difficulté du parcours
provoque généralement de gros rapports
et bien ce ne sera pas le cas cette
année car en dépit du nombre élevé de
concurrents ils étaient 27
les favoris ont tenu leurs promesses le
1 le 5 le 21 donc vous avez été
apparemment nombreux à jouer cette
combinaison il faut dire de manière
générale que les records d'enjeux ont
peut être été battu cette année
en effet les turfistes ont misé à
l'occasion du prix du président de la
république plus de 118 millions de
francs
outre le tiercé le couple et c'est là un
nouveau record 52 mille sept cent
soixante dix-neuf personnes ont touché
ce tiercé dans l'ordre
ils étaient 27 au départ et l'on
attendait généralement des outsiders et
bien sur ce parcours terrible la classe
a parlé pour aborder la rivière du 8
petit louis corps à corps et charles
cats sont en tête du peloton
l'alluré est extrêmement rapide et
pourtant à longue distance de 4700
mètres devront l'effrayer plus d'un
après le groupe les aldudes le 16 à
désarçonner son joker une des
principales difficultés du parcours la
rivière les tribunes est affranchi et
bien la première surprise c'est un sans
faute parfait
mais l'obstacle plus redoutés le juge de
paix attend maintenant les chevaux et
les jockeys à sedan de serre le 21
casaque verte c'est un bon magnifique
le pompier l'un est tout près ainsi que
et pu lui au bout de la ligne d'en face
à sedan le serpent quelques longueurs
d'avancé suivi d' et plus
le pompier est mieux que la dénonce
c'est dans cet ordre que l'on aborde le
dernier tournant l'issue de la course
est toujours incertaine à sedan ne sert
à droite de l'écran a toujours le
meilleur suivi de l'eau pompiers ont
centre nucléaire et non le 5 kazakh noir
qui va très facilement
c'est donc sur le plat que tout va se
jouer à sedan de serre fait une petite
faute au saut du dernier obstacle
nos pompiers se rapproche très vite
suivi de nuque l'année nos florac ayant
blick us dans les derniers mètres
le pompier débordera facilement race
boxer et résistera à la magnifique fans
course de nutte l'année nos attentes
sert lui restera troisième le tiercé le
1 le 5 et le 21 les rapports dans
quelques temps
giscard d'estaing s'adressera donc de
m'asseoir aux français dans une
allocution télévisée sur les trois
chaînes de télévision
l'annnonce de ce rendez vous avec les
français par l'elysée n'est accompagnée
d'aucune autre précision qui pourrait
notamment éclairer les rumeurs de
l'année ventes ul remaniement
ministériel ce matin à lyon dont il
inaugurait la 59ème fois international
monsieur bart a montré du doigt ceux
qu'il appelle les marchands de rêves et
d'illusions ceux qui auront dit-il beau
jeu d d'écrire une france dont tous les
problèmes seraient résolus par
enchantement pour le premier ministre
seul le dur chemin sur lequel le
gouvernement s'est engagé peut conduire
une société de progrès et de justice
dans le respect de la liberté qui a été
au cours des siècles la cité du travail
du courage et de la liberté je voudrais
dire à nos chefs d'entreprise à nos
agriculteurs à nos artisans qu'ils ont
le devoir national de produire de créer
des emplois d'investir d'exporter et que
toute hésitation ou tout attentisme de
leur part ne pourrait que contribuer à
l'issue qu'ils redoutent en mars 1978
je voudrais dire à tous les travailleurs
que des revendications excessives
n'aurait d'autre résultat que de
compromettre leur propre emploi et comme
dans d'autres pays qu'ils peuvent
observer de conduire inéluctablement à
une amputation de leur pouvoir d'achat
et à une baisse de leur niveau de vie
je demande à tous les français
d'accepter les disciplines collectives
sans lesquels notre pays ne peut
conserver ses chances de progrès ni son
indépendance je demande enfin à tous les
responsables politiques quelles que
soient leurs tendances et dont je ne
doute pas d'ailleurs de l'attachement à
leur pays de ne point compromettre par
des attitudes ou des promesses dictée
par le désir de conquérir le pouvoir
le nécessaire
dressement du pays ces propos que je
leur tiens mesdames et messieurs ne
procède d'aucun esprit partisan mais
sont seulement inspiré par les
responsabilités que le président de la
république m'a confiées et que je
m'efforce d'exercer pour le seul service
du pays
voici les principales mesures
économiques annoncées par raymond barre
ce matin à lyon réforme de la sécurité
sociale effort d'information des
français sans doute pour qu'ils
consomment moins et efforts de
modération des dépenses en particulier
d'hôpitaux l'état apportera son aide à
la sidérurgie
l'action et les gens gagen mais aussi il
aidera la construction navale
l'industrie aéronautique celle des
engrais et l'industrie des pâtes et
papiers encouragement aux
investissements l'état mettra quatre
milliards de francs de crédits à la
disposition des entreprises 2 milliards
pour les entreprises petites et moyennes
et les artisans et 2 milliards pour les
grandes entreprises
chômage le gouvernement annoncera d'ici
quelques semaines des mesures destinées
à favoriser l'emploi des jeunes salaires
maintien du pouvoir d'achat en dix ans
soit en 17 mai pas plus sauf pour les
travailleurs rémunérés au smic et aussi
pour les familles augmentation des
allocations familiales plus importante
que par le passé andré bergeron a été
l'un des premiers à réagir à ces mesures
de relance donc annoncé par monsieur
raymond barre a lyon ils les estiment
nécessaire mais il se demande si elles
seront suffisantes quant à françois
ceyrac il a reconnu aujourd'hui à france
inter que le chômage avait pesé d'un
poids indiscutable sur les municipales
ce mardi au lendemain de l'allocution
présidentielle donc jacques chirac va se
rendre à l'elysée
il a confirmé à l'issue du comité
central du rpr aujourd'hui qu'ils le
feraient avec le meilleur esprit et avec
les meilleures intentions le président
du rpr s'est déclaré par ailleurs
favorable à un pacte majoritaire auquel
il apporte quand même
une sorte de wii mais que nous sommes
tout à fait disposés à être dans la
majorité des partenaires loyaux que
cette loyauté nous l'entendons bien
entendu dans les deux sens
c'est à dire que si nous sommes
conscients des devoirs qu'elle nous
impose et prêts à les assumer
nous sommes naturellement également
conscient des droits qu'elle nous donne
droit à nous exprimer droit à être
considéré au niveau qui est le nôtre et
dans cet esprit nous sommes
naturellement désireux d'être l'un des
éléments est l'un des éléments actifs et
déterminant d'une majorité se présentant
unie et cohérente aux prochaines
échéances et au prochain combat
politique
il y à la nécessité d'affirmer nos
propres thèmes et dans les semaines qui
viennent
après plusieurs mois de travail nous
proposerons un certain nombre de thèmes
dont les principaux concerneront la
fiscalité l'environnement la réforme
administrative la culture et
et que nous proposons pour ce qui
concerne le rpr aux françaises et aux
français jacques chirac donc mardi à
l'elysée l'a dit cet après-midi en tant
que maire de paris mais aussi en tant
que président du rpr lors nouvelle
copains c'est aussi à ce double titre
que le président aulas public s'apprête
à recevoir monsieur chirac
oui le prisonnier public va-t-il
accorder à monsieur chirac l'entretien
politique que celui ci espère c'est un
peu la question qu'on se posait cet
après-midi en écoutant les déclarations
de monsieur chirac
il n'y a pas de réponse précise mais il
ya quand même une indication c'est que
l'audience que le président la
république accorder à monsieur chirac
est en fait un tête à tête
alors on dit que s'il avait voulu
recevoir un monsieur chirac uniquement
le maire de paris n'ont pas le président
du rpr et il leur est accordé cette
audience également à quelques-uns des
membres du conseil municipal souhaitait
une visite protocolaire
alors c'est un tête à tête donc on peut
penser que ce sera un entretien
politique en tout cas du côté du rpr
c'est l'espoir que l'on a et que l'on
exprimé cet après midi et ont fait
remarquer que cet entretien politique
s'inscrit dans un enchaînement
aujourd'hui et hier déjà monsieur chirac
a pris le pouls de son parti devant les
instances nationales
il y à cet entretien de mardi et le
lendemain monsieur chirac se rend aux
baux de provence devant le groupe du rpr
le groupe parlementaire du rpr qui se
réunit à la veille ou l'avant veille de
la rentrée parlementaire et donc le de
ce débat de cet entretien va dépendre le
climat des journées parlementaires eu
des airs et à rpr et puis dans une
grande partie aussi le climat général de
la session parlementaire
alors quand monsieur chirac dit oui au
pacte majoritaire il le fait sans aucune
restriction
eh bien il a quand même quelques
restrictions qui l'a exprimé cet après
midi d'abord une restriction c'est que
concerne le changement de loi électorale
monsieur chirac lui-même on le sait déjà
depuis longtemps et contre le changement
de mode de scrutin il l'a rappelé cet
après midi mais ce que l'on peut
constater c'est qu'il ya quand même une
évolution c'est à dire que l'attitude
général du rpr n'est pas une attitude de
principe
on commence en plus des arguments
d'opportunités monsieur chirac lui-même
expliqué cet après midi que l'on ne
pouvait pas changer un mode de scrutin
sera leur disait-il d'un tour de passe
passe au lendemain d'un échec électoral
et un an seulement de nouvelles
élections d'élections législatives
et puis l'autre restriction ou celle ci
est soulignée d'avant
h c'est une restriction concernant
l'europe et plus particulièrement le
projet d'élection et du parlement
européen au suffrage universel et là
monsieur chirac a souligné nettement des
réticences ou des réserves importantes
on sent je crois l'influencent de michel
debré qui a eu paraît-il une sorte de
triomphe lorsqu'il a exposé ce matin ses
idées sur sur l'europe
il faut faire le mitterrand d'ailleurs a
eu aussi à préciser oui alors je crois
que l'on peut opposer à ces réticences
souligné de monsieur chirac le oui
réaffirmé de monsieur mitterrand tout à
l'heure dans le cadre du club de la
presse d'europe alors valéry giscard
d'estaing ce sera donc adressée la
veille de cette visite de monsieur
chirac aux français donc demain soir à
20 heures sur la télévision je le disais
tout à l'heure le nom de cette
allocution ne permet pas pour l'instant
de préciser si finalement il y aura un
remaniement ministériel ou par nom ne
sait toujours rien mais en attendant les
rumeurs s'enfle elle se précise ont
commencé à donner des noms monsieur
untel qui traitait le poste serait
remplacé par monsieur untel si vous le
voulez bien nous n'entrerons pas dans ce
jeu je crois que tout ce que l'on peut
dire ce soir c'est que s'il y a remué
remaniement ministériel
ce remaniement ne serait pas lié à une
remise en cause d'une politique cette
politique était clairement réaffirmé ces
jours-ci par le président de la
république lui-même mercredi dernier
devant le conseil des ministres on a
parlé à ce moment là de sa déclaration
et puis aujourd'hui même par le premier
ministre qui dans son discours de lyon a
dressé un bilan un bilan de sa politique
de la politique économique il a mené
depuis sept mois a sorti d'ailleurs il
faut bien le dire aussi d'une petite
critique de la situation qu'il avait
trouvé en septembre dernier
et puis en plus du bilan il ya aussi les
perspectives et une fois de plus
monsieur bara bien situer son action
dans le temps en expliquant c'était un
enfant un effort de longue durée de
plusieurs années donc il n'y a pas de
remise en cause de la politique
et s'il ya remaniement je pense que ce
serait plutôt lié une réorganisation de
la majorité c'est pourquoi ces jours ci
il était beaucoup question du rôle et de
la place de ce qu'on appelle des
ministres politiques c'est à dire de ces
ministres qui ont aussi des
responsabilités dans des partis
politiques mais je pense que même là il
faut pas trop s'aventurer
nous en serons peut-être davantage de
nous alors je rappelle simplement une
phrase prononcée par valéry giscard
d'estaing c'était vendredi il faut être
courageux lorsqu'on est
amine une situation ce qui donne
peut-être un peu le sens de son
intervention de demain et puis j'ai
enlevé aussi cette cette phrase de
françois mitterrand qui était interviewé
par radio cologne le premier secrétaire
du parti socialiste estime que le
changement opéré par le parti communiste
français devenu une réalité qu'ils
qualifient d'historique le programme
commun dit-il encore peut gagner les
élections et si c'est le cas
valéry giscard d'estaing ne sera pas
qualifié pour en empêcher sa réalisation
la nouvelle délimitant la nouvelle des
lycées loin bien sûr les changements
politiques qui se perd dans ce pays en
ce moment concerne quand même 600
millions de personnes le départ d'
indira gandhi ouvre peut-être une ère
nouvelle mais qui n'est pas quand même
s'en aller à à 81 ans monsieur de sai le
nouveau premier ministre indien a besoin
de compter ses partisans et le
ralliement aujourd'hui de deux
personnalités importantes
ancien président du parti socialiste et
président du congrès pour la démocratie
ce ne sera pas de trop plus qu'une
manifestation un symbole
tous les vainqueurs des élections réunis
sur la tombe du mahatma gandhi le père
de la nation indienne encore ébloui par
leur facile victoire les leaders coalisé
du parti jean tu as le parti du peuple
ceux qui ont chassé une dirigants dit du
pouvoir sont venus se recueillir sur le
mausolée de leurs maîtres spirituels
comme pour un retour aux sources comme
pour rayer ces trente dernières années
ce pouvoir du parti rival le congrès qui
régnait depuis l'indépendance en 1947
une fraternité retrouvée malgré les
divisions internes
une nouvelle fois on a fait appel aux
caciques véritable maître spirituel de
l'opposition tous septuagénaires ou
octogénaires tradition étonnant dans un
pays où 40% de la population ont moins
de 14 ans
pendant quatre jours ces hommes âgés à
la santé fragile parfois chancelante
on négocie âprement la succession du
pouvoir le parti du peuple de mort à
venise de sai obtenant juste 50% des
sièges à l'assemblée avait besoin des 28
sièges du parti du congrès pour la
démocratie de jacques gillot mram
l'homme clé de ces élections et au
parlement indien réuni pour la première
fois dans une atmosphère de kermesse
confuse seul le parti gionta a élu son
leader qui est devenu le nouveau premier
ministre de l'inde mohadji de ça le
premier ministre indien qui porte au
front le thi lac le point rouge signe de
sa soumission à dieu est âgé de 81 ans
de santé fragile mais l'esprit alerte
il appartient à la caste la plus haute
celle des bras mine industrielle riche
mais austère vivent de façon assez tic
il passe pour être un bon administrateur
est un homme intègre très rigoriste et
religieux combattant de la première
heure contre les anglais qui l'ont bis
est en prison il est un disciple du
mahatma gandhi plusieurs fois ministre
du congrès dont une fois vice premier
ministre il s'est séparé d'in dire à
gandhi en 1969 lors de la scission du
parc connu mais peu populaire c'est un
homme de droite
je suis de droite dit-il parce que je
choisis toujours le droit chemin
aujourd'hui il est symbolise le
changement historique de l'ain
et le ps doit que les fraudes les nôtres
l'indépendance doit être non seulement
complètement restauré mais garantie pour
le futur
aucun gouvernement ne doit plus avoir la
possibilité d'appliquer l'état d'urgence
vont modifier la constitution pour que
cela ne se renouvelle pas les violations
de la constitution seront rectifiées
nous devons apprendre aux peuples à ne
plus craindre le retour avec un
événement aucune démocratie ne peut être
sauvé lorsque le peuple peuvent elles
laissent de people s nos démocraties
0,16 devra donc travailler à restaurer
la coque étrangères sur un seul du non
événement je veux dire un véritable d'un
alignement ne soit ni suspecté de
préférence ni accusé de suivre la voie
d'une autre nation notre propre
aujourd'hui les hommes au pouvoir ont
plus de principe que deux programmes
leur but était de chasser indira gandhi
ils y sont parvenus grâce à ces millions
d'électeurs lassé par les abus de l'état
d'urgence regroupés de l'extrême droite
à l'extrême gauche par souci électoral
ils doivent maintenant chercher leur
cohésion
mais déjà les premières divisions
apparaissent la lutte pour le pouvoir
était chaude et laissent des
meurtrissures et des failles l'
équilibre de la majorité est fragile et
la liberté retrouvée risque de se payer
cher
si les mesures économiques pour lutter
contre l'inflation et pour éviter
l'agitation sociale ne sont pas prises
rapidement
le virage brutal et spectaculaire de
l'inde ait été pris dans le calme mais
maintenant des millions d'indiens
attendent un véritable changement qui
concrétisent leurs espoirs
un nouveau concorde va voler sous les
couleurs d'air france ce sera le
quatrième
mais aussi le 11e pour la production
franco britannique il faut savoir que
les 3 premiers n'ont pas permis pour
l'instant de gagner le pari commercial
est loin de là en fait vous savez tout
reste lié à l'autorisation
d'atterrissage des autorités de new york
affaire de persuasion mais aussi
d'ingéniosité en matière de promotion
d'un peut-être parfois besoin d'un plus
petit que soi
ça y est le problème du bruit réseau lui
suffisait d'y penser des réacteurs en
fut simplement été remplacée par le
moteur à hélice devant ce geste de bonne
volonté des ingénieurs français les
américains ont levé leur veto nous
pouvons donc vous annoncer que concorde
atterrira à new york le 1er avril
prochain pour participer à un grand
concours de maquettes
celle ci mesurent deux mètres cinquante
de long et peut voler pendant une demi
heure
elle a été construite par deux
fanatiques des modèles réduits un peu
chauvin qui espère bien que leur succès
rejaillira sur notre concorde nationale
que le monde entier ne nous envie pas il
reste encore à procéder à quelques
menues réglages avant la grande parade
américaine car devant le public new
yorkais beaucoup plus difficile que nos
badauds d'aero club il serait vraiment
trop bête de casser du bois
j'apprends à l'instant que maurice
villemin président de marseille 13 et
nouveau président de l'olympique de
marseille est décédé aujourd'hui dans
les couloirs du stade vélodrome
la suite d'une crise cardiaque à la fin
d'un match de championnat de france de
jeu à xiii marseille lézignan les
milieux du football n'ont pas apprécié
semble-t-il la nouvelle campagne de
lutte contre le dopage déclenché ce
week-end dimanche en particulier par
monsieur jean pierre soisson le
secrétaire d'état à la jeunesse et aux
sports christian lopez le futur
capitaine à partir de mercredi pour
mercredi au moins de l'équipe de france
est choqué il n'y a pas de dopage dit il
dans le football
michel hidalgo affirme que c'est une
erreur et qu'en 25 ans de carrière lui
non plus n'a jamais rencontré de joueurs
de football qui se de paix quant à
bernard thévenet et bien ils étaient
disons beaucoup plus modeste ce matin au
départ du critérium national
il a reconnu publiquement que la
fédération cycliste de l'inscrire sur la
liste noire depuis le conte drôle de
paris-nice mais ils demandent quand même
une contre expertise
pierre-alain des informations je crois
de dernière minute oui une catastrophe
aérienne s'est produite tout à l'heure à
santa cruz de tenerife aux canaries
deux avions sont entrés en collision au
dessus de l'aéroport l'un des appareils
serait un jumbo jet la catastrophe
aurait fait plus de cent morts
et puis les rapports du tiercé dans le
prix du président de la république à
auteuil des rapports décevant la
combinaison 1,5 21 rapporte dans l'ordre
810 francs et dans un ordre différent
160 de francs seulement ce qui
finalement normal quand les favoris
tiennent leurs promesses les chaplin à
paris c'est un événement surtout
lorsqu'ils sont au complet enfin disons
presque tous au complet lorsque charles
aussi s'apprête à réapparaître sur les
écrans gentleman trump qui sort mardi
soir une sorte de biographie par l'image
d'un personnage qui ne passionne pas
seulement les industriels du cinéma un
film concernant charlie chaplin est
toujours un événement mais gentlemen
tram constitue comme une synthèse de
tout ce que nous connaissons sur charlot
c'est peut être pour cette raison que
les enfants chaplin sont venus tous
ensemble cet après midi
ries pour y représenter leur père retenu
en suisse un événement rarissime dans
cette photo de famille vous donne la
prime
géraldine l'aîné rejoindre avait sept
autres demain monsieur d'argol serait
presque pu figurer dans ce tableau
familial
monsieur d'argol c'est ce collectionneur
qui a pu grâce à ses talents de fureteur
et son extrême patience constitué dans
sa maison un véritable musée chapelet il
a couru les brocanteurs et des
bouquinistes résultat un stock
prodigieux de masques de gadgets de
statuettes de t-shirts de boîtes
d'allumettes de badges et de briquets
sur lesquels on trouve comme un refrain
une seule idole car les chaplin charlot
le gentleman vagabond c'est avant hier
celle de 1939 qui avoue tout a démarré
mes parents m'avaient offert un pâté
baby 9,5
c'était c'était un projet à un appareil
de projection à manivelle qui m'a permis
de décors pitié des d'apprécier les
premiers courts métrages de charlot et
de là est née une une certaine
fascination pour le personnage
pour moi ce charlot était le symbole de
l'idéal est de la perfection
m
e
vous avez charlot dans la peau comme ça
finalement si on veut
voilà peut-être une nouvelle maladie
d'ailleurs là le charlot manille
j'aurais voulu terminer sur ce sourire
malheureusement les dépêches qui
commencent à arriver depuis l'annnonce
de cet accident sur santa cruz de
tenerife ne nous permettent pas il
semble que les deux avions qui sont
entrés donc en collision au dessus de
santa cruz de tenerife soit des jumbo
jet donc des avions gros porteurs
appartenant à la panam américaine et à
la compagnie klm
il y aurait donc plusieurs centaines de
victimes
carlin je pense vous en dira davantage
au cours de son journal de 23 heures
bonsoir